(مكالمة واحدة مع بوتين
أوصلت ماكرون إلى هذه الحالة)،
فكيف الحال مع بقية القادة الغربيين؟...
(اسمع جعجعة ولا أرى طحينا،
نسمع وعودهم ولا نرى نتائجها)
هكذا يستمر زيلينسكي بتصريحاته
في ظل خيانة أمريكية جديدة، ..
أوروبا تنفي أنها تتجه لحظر واردات روسيا
من الغاز والنفط، وأمريكا تعلن
حظر شامل لمنتجات روسيا النفطية،
وبوتين يجهز حزمة إجراءات
لتفادي عقوبات الغرب،
وتحذير روسي من ارتفاع جنوني
وغير مسبوق لأسعار النفط العالمية،
فهل يبدأ العالم بتلقي خسائره
بسبب الأزمة الأوكرانية؟ ...
البيت الأبيض يؤكد أن العقوبات
لن تؤتي ثمارها مع بوتين
بل ستأتي بنتيجة عكسية،..
والتوترات تزداد بين الأمريكان والروس
وحرب باردة تحتدم وتصل بالطرفين
لإشعال فتيل الحرب العالمية الثالثة،
فمن يوقف هذه الحرب؟
خيانة أمريكية جديدة:
قال الكونغرس  أن الجيش الأمريكي سحب مكونا
حساسا من صواريخ ستينغر قبل تسليمها لأوكرانيا..
رئيس أوكرانيا زيلينسكي:
المسؤولية تقع على من وعدونا
وأخلفوا وعودهم، وعلى من لم يتمكنوا
من اتخاذ القرار في الغرب لمدة أسبوعين،
وعلى الذين لم يستطيعوا فرض حظر جوي
على من يقتلوننا، وعلى من لم يستطيعو
منع الضربات الجوية عنا،
رغم قدرتهم على ذلك إلا أننا لا زلنا
نسمع وعودا ولا نرى الوفاء بها!!
أعلن الرئيس الأمريكي جو بايدن
حظر شامل على واردات الولايات المتحدة
من الغاز ومنتجات الطاقة الروسية،
وحظر الاستثمار الأمريكي في قطاع الطاقة الروسي،
وقال بايدن أن القرار يحظى بدعم الحزبين
الديمقراطي والجمهوري في الكونغرس،
وأنه اتخذه بعد مشاورات مع حلفاء
أمريكا في أوروبا والعالم..
روسيا: الجيش الوطني الأوكراني
انسحب من محطة زابوريجيا النووية،
والجنود الأوكران سلموا أسلحتهم
بعد توقيع اتفاقية مع الجنود الروس
بعدم قتالهم والانسحاب كليا من المعارك..
وهناك أعلنت موسكو إحكام سيطرتها
على محطة زابوريجيا النووية بالكامل ..
فيما أعلن رئيس المفوضية الأوروبية
جوزيب بوريل أن أوروبا لن تحظر
صادرات الطاقة الروسية ولن يتبعوا
بايدن بهذا الشأن، فقد فرضنا عقوبات اقتصادية
كافية لإثقال كاهل موسكو
ولا داعي للمزيد بحسب قوله.
روسيا تتهم الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية
بإنتاج أسلحة بيولوجية في أوكرانيا،
وقالت موسكو أنها لا تشكل خطرا على الناتو،
وليس لديها النية لفعل ذلك..
بوتين يوقع على إجراءات اقتصادية خاصة،
لمواجهة عقوبات الغرب،،..
ومنها:
*حظر استيراد وتصدير منتجات ومواد
خام من روسيا وإليها عام ٢٠٢٢.
وينص قرار بوتين على أن الحظر لن يؤثر
على المنتجات التي تدخل ضمن احتياجات
المواطن اليومية..
روسيا تكشف عن وثائق سرية قالت
إنها لعمليات هجومية، كانت أوكرانيا
تخطط لها في دونباس، قبل أن تتحرك
موسكو وتنفذ عملياتها العسكرية
وحذر نائب رئيس الوزراء الروسي
ألكسندر نوفاك من أن أسعار النفط
قد ترتفع لتصل ٣٠٠دولار للبرميل الواحد،
في حال حظر إمدادات النفط الروسية،
وهدد بقطع إمداد النفط إلى ألمانيا
وقال أن لديهم كل الحق لحظر الغاز
عن أوروبا وأن أوروبا ستحتاج لعام كامل
لتوفير بدائل للغاز والنفط الروسيين
أمريكا ترسل بطاريتي صواريخ باتريوت
أرض جو إلى بولندا،  لمواجهة أي خطر..
فيما كان البنتاغون قد رفض اقتراحا
بولنديا بنقل الطائرات المقاتلة
من وارسو إلى ألمانيا لتكون تحت
تصرف الولايات المتحدة لتسليمها إلى أوكرانيا،،
ورد البنتاغون بأن هذا شأن بولندي
وليس لأمريكا علاقة به..
مديرة الاستخبارات الأمريكية:
من غير المرجح أن تردع العقوبات
بوتين وقد تدفعه للتصعيد
(الأحداث والتطورات)
(هذا هو حال من يتفاوض مع زعيم روسيا)
قصر الإليزيه ينشر صورا للرئيس الفرنسي
ماكرون موضحا أن الصور تظهر
إحباط ماكرون عقب مكالمة هاتفية
دامت لساعتين مع الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
عن الحرب الروسية في أوكرانيا..
وقال ماكرون أن المفاضات مع بوتين صعبة!!!
ولن يتم التوصل إلى تسوية في الوقت القريب،،
وأكد ماكرون أنه سيواصل مساعيه الحثيثة
للتوصل إلى حل سلمي في أوكرانيا..
وزير الأعمال البريطاني:
فرض حظر تدريجي على استيراد الغاز
والنفط الروسي على أن يصبح شاملا مع الوقت،
قالت نائبة وزير الخارجية الأمريكي
للشؤون السياسية، فيكتوريا نولاند،
خلال جلسة استماع في الكونغرس:
"تتوفر لدى أوكرانيا منشآت خاصة
بالأبحاث البيولوجية. نحن قلقون من أن
القوات الروسية يمكن أن تحاول بسط السيطرة عليها.
ونعمل مع الأوكرانيين على تمكنهم
من منع وقوع أي من هذه المواد
في قبضة القوات الروسية".
ولفتت نولاند إلى أن الولايات المتحدة
ستسعى إلى إلحاق "هزيمة استراتيجية"
بروسيا في أوكرانيا.
بايدن يعلن حظر الولايات المتحدة
واردات النفط من روسيا ردًا على غزوها أوكرانيا
وقال بايدن إن قرار الحظر اتُخذ "بتنسيق وثيق"
مع حلفاء الولايات المتحدة، متابعًا "
لن نساهم في دعم حرب بوتين".
لكن الولايات المتحدة هي مصدّرة بحتة للطاقة
أي أنها تُنتج كميات نفط وغاز أكثر من حاجتها
الاستهلاكية، حسبما ذكّر بايدن.
وأوضح "يمكننا اتخاذ هذا القرار فيما
لا يستطيع آخرون ذلك".
وتابع "لكننا نعمل بشكل وثيق مع أوروبا
وشركائنا لوضع استراتيجية على المدى الطويل
من أجل تخفيف اعتمادهم على الطاقة الروسية".
كذلك، تدرس اليابان، من بين خيارات أخرى،
فرض حظر على واردات الطاقة الروسية،
بحسب وسائل إعلام يابانية.
أما شركات النفط فتعلن الواحدة تلو الأخرى
انسحابها من روسيا. فقد سارت شل على خطى
"بي بي" و"إكسون موبيل" الأميركية
و "إيني" الإيطالية.
ولا يشكّل النفط الروسي
إلّا 8% من الواردات الأميركية و4%
من استهلاك المشتقات النفطية في الولايات المتحدة
التي لا تستورد الغاز الروسي.
وحتى قبل غزو أوكرانيا،
انخفضت واردات الولايات المتحدة بالفعل
إلى حد كبير.
الجيش الأمريكي يطلب من قواته المتواجدة
في أوروبا الاستعداد للاستجابة الفورية
لمنع أي عدوان إضافي من الروس
قد يشكل حربا عالمية تبدأ في القارة الأوروبية..
ولمنع القوى العظمى من الحرب فيما بينها..
ويبلغ عدد الجنود الأمريكان في أوروبا
٦٧ألف جندي.
روسيا تستعرض فيديوهات لما يمكن لطائرات
التمساح الخاصة بها أن تفعله في سماء أوكرانيا..
وأمريكا تعلن مواصلة الدعم لجميع الأوكرانيين..
سواءا من بقي منهم في البلاد ومن هاجر
ومن تضرر، وتعلم أمريكا في قرارة نفسها
أن الحرب ستكون طويلة الأمد،
بينما يحاول الأمريكان حصر الحرب
في حدودها الحالية فهل سيصلوا لهدفهم؟
أم أن للروس كلاماً آخر؟
لماذا تريد روسيا قصف أقمار ستار لينك؟
هذه الإقمار التابعة لشركات الملياردير الأمريكي
إيلون ماسك والتي توفر انترنت للأوكرانيين
بدون انقطاع، وهذا ما جعل روسيا تحاول قصفها،
ستار لينك هي خدمة أطلقتها  شركة سبايس إكس
التابعة لإيلون ماسك لتوفير خدمة إنترنت مجانية
للعالم عبر الأقمار الصناعية ومن دون أسلاك
أو كابلات توصيل ...
موسكو تبث صورا حصرية تقول إنها لرتل عسكري
خلال تنفيذه عملية خاصة في أوكرانيا..
روسيا تمضي نحو وجهتها وأمريكا
لا حول لها ولا قوة،
وسط تضرر الطرفين من الناحية الاقتصادية
والخسائر يصل أثرها للعالم أجمع،
فهل تقف الأمور عند هذا فقط؟
أم أن هذا ليس إلا بداية لكارثة عالمية؟